[موسيقى]
نحييكم من جديد حفيد المهاجرين يقرر ان
يتبع الاساليب الاكثر صرامه يقول البعض مع
قضيه الهجره فاقد تعهد رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك بانهاء الطلبات
المتراكمه لطلب اللجوء حيث اعلن عن
اجراءات جديده تهدف للحد من اعداد
المهاجرين الذين يصلون الى المملكه
المتحده عن طريق عبور القناه الانجليزيه
على متن قوارب صغيره وقال انه يعتزم ايضا
الدفع بمشروع قانون جديد اوائل العام
المقبل لضمان عدم تمكن الاشخاص الذين
يصلون بشكل غير قانوني من البقاء في
البلاد كذلك اوضح رئيس الوزاره البريطانيه
انه اضاف مئات الموظفين لتوالي معالجه
طلبات اللجوء وتصفيه الطلبه المتراكمه
وتقدر باكثر من
143,000 معلق بحلول نهايه العام المقبل
واشار سوناك لان اطقم العمل الاضافيه سوف
تركز ايضا على بعد السريع للمهاجرين
الالبان ممن وصلوا عبر القناه باعداد
متزايده اما باعادتهم لبلادهم او لبلاد
ثالث بينما يتم بحث طلباتهم للوجوب
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من لندن احمد
سعدون الخبير القانوني في شؤون الهجره
واللجوء اهلا بك من لندن كذلك صحفي محمد
هو اهلا
بكمين واسمحالي ان ابدا معك استاذ شبارو
قبل ان نقف على تفاصيل قانونيه خليني اقف
معك على كيف يتابع البريطانيون هذا
الاجراء الجديد ريش صنعك بالامس في
تغريدته الاخيره قال وعدت في همم قبل
الانتخابات وبدات بالتنفيذ والتنفي ظهور
لهذه الاجراءات يتمثل ليس فقط في العمل
على الحد من عمليات لجوء بل الى البدء في
تكوين اليه لارجاع اللاجئين فهل تعتقد بان
هذه الاستراتيجيه استراتيجيه سليمه وبانه
سيكون هناك تقبل لها في الدخل البريطاني
طبعا استاذ ريم يعني سؤال مهم للغايه
المجتمع البريطاني متعاطف مع طالبي اللجوء
ولا طالما كانت بريطانيا في مقدمه الدول
التي استقبلت الوافدين الذين يحتاجون
للحمايه على مدى العقود الماضيه المساله
اليوم هي مساله او ما يسعى الى منعي حدوثه
رئيس الوزراء ريس هناك من خلال التشريعات
الجديده التي تدعو الى تشكيل قياده موحده
للتعامل مع هذه الافه هي افه من نظر
الحكومه البريطانيه ادجار بالبشر اي همم
هناك همم تجار سماسره في اكثر من دوله
يعملون على كسب الاموال او التكسب المادي
من خمسه الى عشره الاف جنيه لقاء ايصال
وتهريب هذا الشخص او ذاك الى البر
البريطاني هذه هي المساله الاساسيه التي
اعتقد ان معظم البريطانيين ايضا يرفضونها
وان كانوا يقول ان بريطانيا تتمسك بدورها
لحمايه ومنح اللجوء السياسي والحمايه
اللازمه للمحتاجين والهاربين من نزاعات
ومناطق مضطربه في العالم ولكن مساله
الاتجار بالبشر يجب وضع حد لها ومعروف ان
القيادات الامنيه البريطانيه والاوروبيه
قامت عده عمليات امنيه خلال الاشهر
الماضيه
وقامت بضرب جماعات همم تعمل على تهريب
البشر من اوروبا الى بريطانيا استاذ احمد
كيف ترى الموضوع هل ترى بان هذه
الاستراتيجيه تدخل فعليا في محاوله وقف
عمليه الاشجار بالبشر او كما تقول الامم
المتحده لان المفوضيه الساميه كذلك بالامم
المتحده كانت تعلقت على هذا الموضوع ولما
احد الى عدم قانونيه هذه الاجراءات وحتى
انها اشارت وكانها المحت الى تميز او الى
تمييز بالعكس يقوم به ريشه هناك بخصوص هذه
الاجراءات تقول
همم المفوضيه ساميه بان رئيس وزاره
البريطاني يميز بين الواصلين البريطانيا
عبر قوارب صغيره وبين اللاجئين بطرق
قانونيه وتعتبر الامر مرفوض
حضرتك
العربيه لتصل على هذا ال- ال- الموضوع
الحساس اللي حقيقه دائره الهجره
البريطانيه طبعا
يعني باختصار
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
بامكانه انها تلك المشكله هو القضاء على
ما في التهريب حتى اكون دقيق في التعبير
في نفس الوقت قبل اسابيع اتفق مع الحكومه
الفرنسيه مع وزاره الداخليه همم وزيره
الداخليه
كانت في زياره خاطفه الى باريس واتفقت على
انه هو تم الاتفاق اعطاء 60 مليون جنيه
استرليني ما يسمى مساعده الدرك همم
الفرنسي همم طائرات مسيره ونوافير ليليه
وكذلك الدوريات همم دائما تكون موجوده
لمراقبه همم
همم
والمهربين وكذلك اللاجئين الذين يصلون عبر
عبر بحر الماعز السؤال اللي هو يطرح نفسه
انه بامكان همم فرنسا هي هي ال ال يعني
العائق الكبير همم بصراحه والمشكله
الكبيره من 2015 لحد هذه اللحظه او حتى
اكون دقيقه من 2010 الى حد هذه اللحظه انه
اللي حصل انه فرنسا رافعه الرايه البيضاء
من زمن الرئيس ساركوزي هولاند امينيوال
ماكرون هذا اللي حصل على انه لم يقدمه لم
يعطوا طلب لشخص ان كان عراقي او سوري او
او افغاني او علما هناك من يستحق ان يعطى
حق الحمايه وحال وصوله بريطانيا تتحمل
كبير لكن انا من وجهه نظري بامكان انه
مكافحه مافيه التاريخ ومعاقبتهم ومتابعتهم
بتعاون جهاز المخابرات البريطاني مع مع
جهاز المخابرات الرومانسيه
استاذ احمد
لم افهم الجزئيه تفضلت بها تقول بان فرنسا
لم تقبل همم اللاجئين همم فرنسا من اكثر
البلدان اللي تقبل كل يوم لاجئين جدد
سوريين عراقيين حضرتك ذكرت بعض الجنسيات
ولكن همم لم افهم مشكله فرنسا مع بريطانيا
بما يخص بحر الماء او ايه
فرنسا اصلا قبل سنتين او ثلاث سنوات غلقت
ما يسمى بمخيم الرعب في كاليه فرنسا دائما
يعني هذا الكلام ليس من عندي هذا كلام من
اللاجئين انا على على على على تما بهذا
الامر انه طالب اللجوء عندما يتم القاء
القبض عليه في في في كاله حتى هناك همم
كلاب بوليسيه همم يتكلم معها ضابط الدرك
الفرنسي باللغه يعني همم
بالانجليزيه انه همم بروكن يعني لغه ركيكه
يقول لها انه ترينكس تايم انه يحاول مره
اخرى فلذلك لا توجد هناك عقوبه حقيقيه
عندما يتم امساك طالب اللجوء وهو متوجه
الى الاراضي البريطاني كان بامكان انه
دراسه
يستحق هل يستحق طلب الحمايه او لا همم
همم مسؤوليه فرنسا في ما والف بريطانيا هل
لان فرنسا هي فعلا في ما يخص مخيم كالي
همم وكانت هناك مشاكل عديده فما يخص هذا
المخيم ولكن هل المشكله في فرنسا او في
بعض الدول الاخرى التي تبني استراتيجيه
جديده لعدم قبول اللاجئين او المشكله في
بريطانيا والمشكله اكثر في ريش السوناتا
الذي يقول عنه البعض رغم انه اتى من عائله
مهاجره ولكن هوى همم يعني همم لا يذهب مع
ولا يتالف مع مثل هكذا همم عائلات هل
المشكله في صنعك
انا اعتقد ان المشكله في سناك بالاخص هناك
مشكله داخليه بريطانيه استاذه ريم ان هناك
بحاجه ليثبت انه رئيس وزراء قادر على
التعامل مع الملفات الاكثر صعوبه في
اداراته طبعا الشان الاقتصادي هو خلفيته
اقتصاديه يتعامل معها بسهوله واقامه
بموازنه الميزانيه
والاستقرار الاوضاع الداخليه رغم
الاضطرابات رغم كل المشاكل الثانيه موضوع
الهجره واللجوء مساله يعني لطالما غطيتها
بين بريطانيا وفرنسا على مدى 30 عاما
الماضيه وهي كره او كما يسمونها هنا حطوا
تيتو بطاطا ساخنه همم يتم تقادها بين
الادارات البريطانيه المتعقبه وان اكدت
على شيء عدم تاله القوانين البريطانيه
الداخليه لاسيه من قوانين الهجره
المتسامحه جدا مع الوصول اللاجئين ومع حق
حمايتهم وهو معروف عن بريطانيا ذلك منذ
عقود طويله
انها لا تتالف ربما اليوم مع عمليات
التهريب المستجده وايضا التي اصبح عددها
كبير للغايه طبعا هناك همم مساله همم خروج
بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو ما اجج
ايضا عدم وجود مساله او بعض الاليات اللي
كانت التي كانت تلجا اليها الدول لحمايه
او للحد من وجود طالبيه اللجوء وايضا
المهاجرين غير الشرعيه خصوصا هؤلاء نسميهم
همم كراميك مايجراند او المهاجر الاقتصادي
هؤلاء لديهم اموال ان جاءوا من اي بلد من
العالم يدفعونها لقاء تهريبهم الى دوله
يعتقدون انه بامكانهم العمل فيها همم بشكل
همم شرعي او بشكل يعني تحت الطاوله
بالاسود اي عدم دفع الضرائب لفترات طويله
ثم يعودون الى بلادهم وهذا امر موجود في
كافه الدول المساله واتهام فرنسا بعدم
السماح او
وفاه همم قوانينها للهجره همم والسماح
لبقاء المهاجرون كثير من المهاجرين يفضلون
الوصول الى بريطانيا بسبب عامل اللغه وهذا
لمسته همم يعني بلمس اليد في التسعينات
القرن القرن الماضي عندما كنت اذهب الى
مخيم كاليه واسال الوافدين لماذا تريدون
ذهاب الى لا يريدون تعلم الفرنسيه او
الايطاليه او الالمانيه على الطريق
بريطانيا اسهل وقوانينها لديها ثغرات
كثيره يمكن لي
نشطاء وايضا مهربي بشر يعلمون المهاجرين
كيف يتحدثون مع سلطات الامنيه لكي لا يعاد
يعني نقلهم الى الدوله التي وفدوا منها
وهذا واقع يعني وبريطانيا انا اعتقد الحل
هو في بريطانيا وليس في فرنسا او مكان اخر
هو عبر البث بالطلبات كلها بشكل وافي
ومهني وحرفي وبشكل لا يمكن ان تنقذه
المحاكم
استاذ احمد بي كل ذلك اليوم الامم المتحده
تقول بانه هذه الاجراءات تقود التقاليد
الانسانيه في بريطانيا فهل يمكن ان تعرف
هذه الاجراءات بريطانيا لي همم بعض همم
الانتقادات القويه ان لم نتحدث عن اجراءات
همم للحد همم مما سيقوم به او من اليه ريش
الصناعه كانت سيتخذ ضد اللجوء
طبعا هو الامم المتحده للاسف تدخلها خاجول
يعني همم غير خافي عن حضرتك الان كثير من
الملفات العالقه موجوده في في اسطنبول وفي
عمان وفي بيروت لطالب مقدمين عن طريق
الامم المتحده في نفس الوقت يعني همم
يعني غير خاف عن حضرتك كذلك على انه
طالبين لجوء الالبان هم
وجزائريين والمغاربه والتونسيين حتى يكون
دقيق بالتعبير وهم وصلوا يعني عندما يصلون
البريطانيا هم اللي لاسباب اقتصاديه بحته
ليس من لا توجد هناك ما يسمى اثباتات تثبت
انه حياتهم بقطر الا بعدد الاصابع لانه
دائره الهجره دعاما يعني ضباط التحقيق هم
على يعني ناس محترفين على معرفه تامه
بالملف العراقي على معرفه على انه يعرفون
انه في العراق توجد فساد مالي واداري توجد
هناك همم يعني الانسان النزيه همم الموظف
في الدوله عندما يتم استهدافه بطريقه
واخرى سوريا الان هي غابه حقيقيه الانسان
يعني همم في ظروف استثنائيه يعيشها
المواطنه السوري كذلك اليمن كذلك ليبيا
انا من وجهه نظري انهم معالجه سوناك الى
ملفات العالقه هو هذا افضل شيء
بالنسبه لي ياتون لاسباب اقتصاديه للوقت و
سوف يضع في حساباته انه يحصل على اقامه
هذه اللي هم يعتبروها الجنه الموعوده
على المشاركه معنا وكل ما تفضلت ما به من
معلومات من لندن صحفي محمد
والاستاذ احمد سعدون الخبير القانوني في
شؤون الهجره شكرا لكم